well thought it was going to be
something easy Dean Charles Chapman and
George McKay you guys did an amazing job
at portraying Blake and Schofield we
felt like we were running with you every
step of the way the filming technique
that you guys use to convey your
characters stories made watching 1917 an
intense and emotional experience
suddenly we understand why director Sam
Mendes chose to film the movie in a
one-shot sequence while the ambitious
project translated beautifully onto the
screen getting things right the first
time wasn't always easy 1917 is quickly
becoming everyone's favorite war movie
and that's because it stands apart from
the other films in its genre 1917 is
filmed in a one-shot sequence making
viewers feel like they're watching Blake
and Schofield mission unraveled in real
time we're about to reveal how 1917 was
filmed shot by shot and why director Sam
Mendes chose this filming technique to
begin with from the very beginning I
felt this movie should be told in real
time Sam Mendes wanted to convey the
absolute horrors that would go in to
shape the Great War
his grandfather Alfred H Mendes was 17
years old when he became a soldier in
World War one and he lived to tell his
grandson about his side of the story
Sam knew that when it came to directing
1917 a normal movie template just
wouldn't be followed he wanted the raw
emotions of the soldiers to translate
onto the screen and to properly do this
he decided to create a movie that would
make audiences feel like they were
following the movie's main characters in
real time choosing to shoot 1917 in a
one-shot sequence allows audiences to be
fully submerged in the movie's plot as
though they were playing a video game in
which they fear for Blake and
Schofield's lives because if these
messengers failed to carry out their
mission their team would lose and the
words game over would flash across the
screen
we should my case the one shot sequence
helps viewers connect with Blake and
Schofield on a whole other level making
the movie all the more realistic and
emotional this filming technique isn't
typically used due to how complicated
and challenging it can be however if
properly executed it can elevate a movie
shock value while hyping up a viewer
senses using this method
Sam was able to inflict the fear
adrenaline and anxiety the soldiers were
feeling onto the viewers so while there
is a big risk to use the one-shot
filming method there is also a big
reward
but how did Sam manage to pull this off
and who helped him translate his vision
onto the screen well simply put Sam had
to start at square one he needed his
cast members to know exactly what was
going on before introducing the cameras
it took six months for the actors to
rehearse the entire movie before filming
could commence and pressing pause when
someone messed up wasn't always an
option as you can see entire scenes were
filmed in unison and actors were
instructed to stay in character until
the director yelled cut while filming
the soldiers running across the field
you can see actors bumping into each
other falling and getting back up but
while a lot of these run-ins were not
planned they accurately demonstrated the
messiness of a real-life battlefield
obviously two hours of screen time can't
be filmed into one perfect sequence so
Sam had to get creative when introducing
cuts into the film these cuts couldn't
happen midway through an action scene as
they would be easy to spot ruining the
illusion Sam fought so hard to perfect
although Sam's project was ambitious it
wasn't impossible and history would
prove this after all Alfred Hitchcock
managed to perfect the one shot sequence
in 1948 when he used it to create the
movie rope whenever a cut had to be made
the camera would circle an object be it
a tree or a building and only then could
the camera be stopped circling around an
object makes it easy to pick up where
the camera left off allowing the cast to
catch their breath all the while
protecting perfectly filmed footage that
would be rendered useless if someone
made a mistake in real-time Sam used
this editing trick every single time the
camera bent around the maze like
trenches and this came in handy
considering the chaotic nature of these
scenes but Sam didn't work alone when it
came to perfecting the one-shot movie he
had a very experienced and talented
cinematographer on his side which helped
make 1917 an unforgettable cinematic
experience Roger Deakins worked
alongside Sam Mendes to deliver a film
that many directors would deem
impossible the legendary director of
photography
used an Arri Alexa a left digital format
camera to shoot most of the film
Roger introduced several lenses to
achieve Sam's vision which was most
impressive considering that it was
Rogers first time using this type of
camera one of the smallest cameras so
far I've ever use for actors Dean
Charles Chapman and George McKay who
played corporal Blake and corporal
Schofield respectively this movie proved
to be the most challenging of all this
is because as the main characters the
cameras never left their side throughout
the entire film and every single scene
was crucial to the movies success
because simply put nothing could be cut
out of the film as it would tarnish the
storylines continuous landscape but
despite the crews biggest efforts there
is a continuity error in the film that
makes the movies in real time aspect
fall flat now we're not hating on the
movie it's a work of art however there's
no way the two-hour film could have
taken place in real time as the movie
first takes place in daylight only to
leak into nighttime and transpire into
the morning and that's a wrap
before you go tell us what you thought
about 1917 and the way it was shot in
the comments below for more videos like
this be sure to subscribe to the things
and give this video a big thumbs up if
you haven't already we'll see you next
time
thanks for watching
you